where we had time wise time for
questions yeah we are on hopeful advice
with Bobby and kalila all right guys
this is from as armed how can I be part
of an Asian circle of friends I always
see you guys at school in a big group
you seem to have be having so much fun
this is a white guy as are there's
always a you guys always have a lot of
energy I'm not Asian but I occasionally
seen on ages in group so I have hope it
generally seems like it's an exclusive
club I sometimes hang out with whites
but it's only a couple of them and they
always want to watch movies TV and etc
and are generally pretty boring what is
the secret to making friends with Asians
thanks Bobby Lee if you ever watched
Mitch Mulaney here's a comic he has a
joke about that that one white guy
that's that's you know that hangs out
with Asians so he's like more Asian than
that yeah I'm hungry guy don't be that
guy you know it's like you know we live
in America I don't hang out with Asians
my friends are I think he's fetishizing
thank you if you want to hang out with
logic operations and you want to fit
into that that's that's a fetish you
know for me it's like I don't the only
issues I hang out with is you guys David
Cho my brother that's pretty much
growing up not really didn't really have
a lot of white friends Mexican friends
and a lot of my friends and stand-up are
all white and black and Mexican I don't
really hang out with other I mean I'll
see Ali Wong we're friends you know I
mean she's cool but I don't look at her
and go wow there's an Asian girl yeah
Steve Byrnes half asian I don't really
see him as that I I don't have a proper
answer for this country grew up in yeah
with a well no and also when I came from
the Philippines for the first time the
Filipinos all rejected me I was too Fabi
I wasn't Philip I was too Filipino my
accent was too thick and it I don't know
I was probably probably didn't dress
cool and shave my legs there were a lot
of like well because I didn't know that
I didn't I only ever shaved for swim
meets cuz we had to but I didn't know
that boys like shaved legs here I didn't
know a lot of things and I probably you
know
dressed a little backwards because my
parents you know we had already lost a
lot of our money and you know I dressed
like kid when I first talked to Kyle out
on the phone she goes sorry about my
accent she said right away it made me go
oh yeah I was very insecure for a while
because I couldn't I had hard consonants
and I was always called out for it so
when I was in a swim team we would have
to scream out our times to our coach so
let's say like I do like a fifty
butterfly right and I'd have to I'd have
to say like koala what's your tire 26.2
right and I was so insecure how'd it
come out I got 26 point dog I would go
home and practice this Honey 20-20-20
Oregon or mountain mountain cuz I was a
mountain mountain oh no Frigidaire I was
a frigerator refrigerator like I would
practice my heart disease because you
know it it matters when you were 14 and
15 and people are like where the [ __ ]
are you from well you don't look
Filipino and the Filipinos would say
well you're too Filipino so you know who
I hung out with Jessica Korean friend
but she didn't even go to the same
school I only hung out with Mexicans
Mexicans took me in didn't give a [ __ ] I
went to Morken saneras and it's so funny
that you say that because in comedy
there was a time where you had to be
either Mexican black or white in the 90s
and the Mexicans took me in I didn't
laugh evil laugh first of all yeah I did
it's like in prison when you're like
Asian and like I gotta join that's what
happened to me Mexicans yeah Mencia
Willie Barcena
Jeff Garcia Gabriel Felipe Esparza all
those guys I started with because they
were the only ones that took me in
because the white ones I wasn't nerdy
enough or cool enough like Dane was the
thing then you know and the black ones
know so I
the Mexicans harbored me dude but also
Mexicans just have a really really deep
sense of family and a lot of the Mexican
kids that I that I hung out with you
know their families were immigrants
right or they weren't here so so if we
kind
just bonded and that seems says where
it's like oh I was new to the country
their parents were illegal immigrants
and I just party to them all the time
and for a while there no slowness whele
popular Spanish my people and I love
them I love Mexican so much yeah I
really do
they're inclusive yeah they're full of
they're full of party in their heart
yeah I love Mexicans
I love me I don't you know what I'm not
a fan of and I'm gonna get a lot of [ __ ]
for this be careful Tiny's no I'm not a
fan oops
oops Bobby doesn't like we know that a
lot of Filipinos that live in California
catch me dating a Filipino guy either
that's there's something about this
sense of righteousness that the
Filipinos were born here have that is a
complete turnoff California ones yeah
it's like they kind of all bond together
because they have this Filipino clique
but they know nothing about the
Philippines as a country you know
nothing about the history you know
nothing about the language but they're
very kind of like cliquish and they're
like oh but this is all of this is a
flip crew this is a panic room like no
you're not because to them I'm not
Filipino looking enough but I'm too
Filipino acting and they're the ones who
kind of they're they want to go back to
the Philippines and have this this kind
of air like oh but we're the
Americanized Filipinos and I hate that
[ __ ] I don't want to just say this
because you said Filipino Mike I just
want to say anyone if you're gonna come
up to me and recognize me don't go hey
aren't you on YouTube because what that
does is it negates everyone's on YouTube
yeah okay yeah that's what a Filipino
dude at a Mexican restaurant in
Sacramento said that night hey dude are
you on YouTube I go yeah you are too
George can whoa
George can move everyone's on YouTube if
you say hey what you want mad TV or even
Comedy Central is vague but say that
yeah
don't say YouTube and that's the word
[Music]